[ÂM NHẠC]
>> Diễn giả 1: Hãy thực sự bắt đầu đi vào các khái niệm ứng dụng.
Đây hoàn toàn là khái niệm toán học và tôi nghĩ đó là điều duy nhất
chúng tôi làm theo cách đó, mọi thứ khác sẽ được áp dụng ở đây.
Vậy hãy nói về đệ quy,
khá [COUGH] xin lỗi.
Một phần khá quan trọng của phát triển web ở đây hoặc chỉ viết mã nói chung.
Vì vậy, đệ quy là khi bạn định nghĩa một cái gì đó theo nghĩa của chính nó.
Vì vậy, nếu bạn từng hỏi ai đó định nghĩa của một từ và
họ chỉ sử dụng cùng một từ để định nghĩa chính nó.
Một, thật là khó chịu, vì tôi đã không nói với bạn điều gì.
Vì vậy, giống như đệ quy rất không hữu ích trong tiếng Anh.
Tuy nhiên, nó lại rất hữu ích trong khoa học máy tính.
Vì vậy, tôi nghĩ cái tôi có ở đây là máy tính.
Vậy, máy tính là gì?
Đó là thứ tính toán mọi thứ, giống như một thứ gì đó tương tự.
Đó sẽ là một định nghĩa đệ quy.
Nó sử dụng thứ gì đó để xác định chính nó hoặc nếu bạn nhìn vào hình ảnh này ngay tại đây,
chúng ta có một tam giác được tạo thành từ các tam giác khác.
Đây là một tam giác được xác định đệ quy, bởi vì một tam giác được tạo thành từ
hình tam giác, được tạo thành từ các hình tam giác nhỏ hơn,
được tạo thành từ các tam giác nhỏ hơn bên phải.
Đó là bản chất của đệ quy.
Khi được áp dụng cho khoa học máy tính, về cơ bản,
bạn xác định một hàm gọi chính nó.
Vì vậy, bạn đang sử dụng một hàm để xác định chính nó,
mà dường như tâm trí khá uốn cong và nó là.
Giống như lần đầu tiên bạn học đệ quy, thật khó khăn.
Nhưng một khi bạn có được nó, thực sự bạn bắt đầu nhận ra rằng nó khó, nhưng nó đơn giản.
Như tôi đoán, đó là những gì tôi nhận được và nó được sử dụng ở mọi nơi.
Đó là một kỹ thuật rất hữu ích.
Tại sao nó lại rất hữu ích là bạn có các cuộc gọi đệ quy này và
mỗi cấp của cuộc gọi đệ quy có thể duy trì trạng thái riêng của nó,
mà kết quả là rất hữu ích.
Chúng tôi sẽ sử dụng cái đó sau này khi chúng tôi bắt đầu đi vào như sắp xếp hợp nhất,
bởi vì điều đó trở nên rất cần thiết đối với chúng tôi.
Đệ quy rất, rất hữu ích cho một số vấn đề.
Tuy nhiên, nó mang lại một chút chi phí cho nó.
Bởi vì bạn chỉ thực hiện tất cả các lệnh gọi đến hàm này, nó bắt đầu thêm nhiều hơn và
nhiều chức năng hơn cho ngăn xếp.
Chúng ta cũng sẽ nói về ngăn xếp sau.
Ý tưởng cơ bản là việc gọi một hàm không nhất thiết phải miễn phí.
Nó khá gần với miễn phí.
Vì vậy, phần lớn, chúng ta thường bỏ qua chi phí.
Nhưng khi bạn bắt đầu gọi một hàm là 100,
200 lần thực sự mang lại một chi phí, đặc biệt là với bộ nhớ.
Vì máy tính của bạn bây giờ phải theo dõi 200 cuộc gọi bộ nhớ khác nhau và
tại một số điểm, một số người trong chúng ta sẽ thấy tràn ngăn xếp.
Giống như trước hết, mọi người đều sử dụng tràn ngăn xếp.
Đó là cách tôi học lập trình dưới dạng sao chép và dán nó từ tràn ngăn xếp,
nhân tiện là một kỹ năng.
[LAUGH] Nhưng đó là nguồn gốc của tràn ngăn xếp,
nếu bạn đệ quy xuống quá xa, thường bằng đệ quy vô hạn.
Giống như nếu bạn có một đệ quy cứ tiếp diễn mãi mãi,
máy tính của bạn sẽ nói, bạn đang làm cái quái gì vậy?
Tôi sẽ nổ tung và sau đó nó sẽ nổ tung.
Vì vậy, đó là những gì xảy ra tràn ngăn xếp khi bạn bị nguyền rủa quá mức và
cuối cùng máy tính cho biết, tôi đã hết khả năng theo dõi các cuộc gọi mới vào bộ nhớ.
>> Diễn giả 1: Vì vậy, nó không miễn phí, đó là lý do tại sao đệ quy hơi giống một công cụ nặng
không phải là cái mà bạn muốn áp dụng nhẹ.
Nếu bạn có thể thực hiện lặp đi lặp lại, đó thường là cách ưu tiên.
Lặp lại, có nghĩa là bạn làm điều đó với các vòng lặp thay vì đệ quy.
Tuy nhiên, bạn có thể nhớ trước đó tôi đã nói điều đó ở đâu,
bạn muốn ưu tiên khả năng đọc hơn hiệu suất.
Vì vậy, nếu đệ quy làm cho một thứ gì đó rất dễ đọc đối với ai đó, bạn sẽ thấy ở đây
trong một chút mà nó hoàn toàn có, làm điều đó cho một số vấn đề.
Bạn muốn điều đó.
Và sau đó nếu bạn đi sau và
bạn nhận ra rằng đây là một điểm nghẽn lớn trong chương trình của bạn,
đó là tại thời điểm đó bạn được hoạt động để lặp lại thay vì đệ quy.
Vì vậy, luôn luôn, luôn luôn, luôn luôn ưu tiên khả năng đọc.
Bạn sẽ làm cho bản thân và những người khác rất, rất hạnh phúc về lâu dài.
Nói cách khác, đừng khéo léo trừ khi bạn bắt buộc phải như vậy.